dès le départ il s'agissait par une
exposition grand public et parler du
projet urbain mais pas seulement sous
l'angle de l'architecturé l'urbanisme
mais aussi parler de la science du
paysage et de l'aspect économique aussi
lésé par on a cherché à voir comment va
représenter ces différentes disciplines
avec des supports architecturaux et
comment on le rendent communicables est
compréhensible au grand public
comme toile de fond des trois journées
de tables rondes et de conférences
on a proposé de faire une fresque qui en
même temps monumental et en notant
légère qui représente aussi bien des
avancées scientifiques des personnes qui
contribuent au projet comme des lieux
dont certains sont à venir ou d'autres
existants et même des éléments naturels
la difficulté avec un tel projet
d'urbanisme
c'est la très grande échelle et donc on
a choisi de montrer en différentes
échelles le projet d'urbanisme les idées
derrière mais aussi les maquettes des
premiers bâtiments qui sont en cours de
développement
on montre plus un processus qu'un projet
finit donc par exemple il ya des
maquettes de concours qui sont des
versions la première des projets
architecturaux qui sont toutes exposées
en arrière chapelle et les matériaux
utilisés sont des matériaux de chantier
brut dans notre équipe qui avec michel
desvigne paysagiste il ya un énormément
d'ingénieurs de différentes spécialités
d'experts de tous genres c'est vraiment
un projet transdisciplinaire et
collaboratif si on travaille sur le plan
urbain depuis à peu près cinq ans mais
on est certain que l'ensemble ça durera
15 ans et ce sera une évolution dans le
temps qui n'arrête jamais
sacré maintenant devient une réalité sur
le terrain on voit des grues qui
apparaissent un peu partout on voit des
chantiers qui se met en place le
transport en commun en site propre qui
est en train d'être réalisé on a pensé
que c'était utile et important de le
faire savoir à l'ensemble des
communautés intéressées par ce genre de
par ce projet et au grand public
l'idée c'est de montrer à la fois le
projet d'ensemble donc ça commence à
être impressionnant et dès l'année
prochaine les chantiers vont encore se
multiplier pour la mise en oeuvre